Hi, Mr. Switzer.
I'm Jennifer from Speech Therapy.
How are you doing today?
I've been better.
Okay.
I just want to make sure before we get started that I'm talking to the right person,...
...so I just want to check your name band.
Can you tell me your name and your birthday?
Max Switzer.
11 / 25 / 1984.
So first, I just want to take a look inside your mouth.
Is that okay?
Here's my flashlight, it's kind of big.
Can you open real wide for me?
Good, can you say uh-uh-uh?
Uh-uh-uh.
Good, can you stick your tongue out as far as you can?
Good, and move it side to side.
Perfect, and up and down.
Great, and smile really big.
Good, and pucker and say ooh.
Good, any numbness or tingling in your face, your lips, your cheeks?
No.
It all feels normal?
Yeah.
Good.